I'll watch the kids today.
Why don't you just go relax or something?
I can see that you're tired.
It wouldn't be anything for me to take care of the dishes as well.
As a matter of fact, while I'm at it, I might as well do the wash for you, too.
It's what husbands are for, right?
Isn't this what wives want to hear?
Although husbands don't need to do all the above things all at once,...
...imagine how good a wife would feel if her husband did some of them on a regular basis.
My father, for example, always does the dishes because my mother always does the cooking.
It's a win-win situation.
He doesn't like cooking, and she doesn't like doing the dishes.
Let's look at the flip side of the same coin.
The husband returns from a hard day of work.
He's tired and just wants to relax, and really doesn't want to talk or think about anything for a little while...
...until he unwinds.
Imagine the wife noticing this and saying,...
..."You must have had a long day at work!"
How about just going into the other room and taking a nap?
I'll run the errands for you.
I might be exaggerating a little here, but my point is this,...
...for a marriage to work, each person should be looking out for the other person before themselves.
If couples did even small things now and again for each other,...
...there would be fewer rocky relationships in this world.